monsieur le président on peut
légitimement s'interroger sur la
situation critique que traverse la
société française le pensez-vous pas y
être sourd pour un puissant j'ai
beaucoup de défauts et on peut toujours
faire mieux mais je ne crois pas avoir
été saoul
c'est une attaque de drone
et civils des enfants des hommes des
femmes alors super super
[Musique]
c'est incroyable comme les gens thème
est la plus grande journaliste de france
france pourquoi ce besoin de te remettre
en selle le gars qui élabore la ti
solaire est grandissant d'un but
l'impression d'avoir une mission pas
génial talent qu'elle a cette fille vous
savez tous été formidables formidable
c'était formidable ne pas mourir pour
les journalistes on changera quand vous
courez après l'audimat ça fait donc aux
leçons de morale vous les gardez pour
vous les vôtres et vous idiots utiles ça
va aller ma puce aurait un effet dire
pour choisir des bijoux et l'arabe
je ne supporte plus le regard des gens
les gens vont te détester puis tu adores
et c'est la même chose
c'est par tokyo marie c'est pas ton
argent c'est notre argent je gagne 5
fois plus que toi ça explose
c'est génial
[Musique]
théâtre
ça la matière des icônes
elles ont fait 2 2 me jean crevettes ce
métier sucette elle pleure la france
maintenant
cette célébrité sidérante
c'est la télé pour moi c'est comme ça
que ça marche
le pire c'est de mieux